j'ai hurlé ouais ça y est j'ai aussi un
pari et on va d mahdi attaque d'elle tu
vas là cervelli je suis arrivé en
janvier le 11 janvier 2000 et je suis
avisé dans le 11e but qui sonne voilà
c'est la rue où j'habite et la première
fois en fait je suis arrivé en france
l'appartement ils étaient tous minuscule
et moi quand j'ai vu en fait le salon où
il y avait la cuisine je croyais que
c'était juste la cuisine qu'elle là je
peux vous dire que j'ai regretté ma
maison évolutive à cela et à l'époque la
porte elle était verte je demandais à
ceux qui étaient déjà partis en europe
comment il fera comme il fait froid et
les gens me disaient tu vois le
congélateur là bas mais ta tête dedans
pendant une demi heure et a fait là
quand je suis arrivé et j'ai compris
qu'il faisait vraiment très très froid
donc du coup je me suis dit tiens on va
aller à barbès faut s'acheter de quoi se
réchauffer la première fois que j'ai
pris le métro je voulais faire le comme
une grande je suis descendu tout seul
j'ai vu les gens descendent je suis
descendu avec eux j'ai vu le métro à
vider et ensuite j'ai pas eu le temps
le métro a ouvert ses portes et ça
sifflait et moi je ne savais pas et j'ai
couru je suis allée est en fait la force
et sans vraie tournée sur noir et ça m'a
traumatisée et début je ne voulais plus
prendre le métro
et en plus dans le métro personnes
lésées biberon
les gens ne se parlent pas et moi je
c'était impossible pour moi de rentrer
de m'asseoir comme ça il n'est même pas
les garder les gens quoi donc du coup je
disais bonjour bonjour bonjour personne
ne répondait pas quand je suis arrivé à
barbès
je suis sortie du métro et là je me suis
dit will come to africa
ah mais je déchire moi je disais bonjour
à tout le monde les gens me répondait
mais c'était vraiment génial j'étais
heureuse de retrouver cette chaleur la
peau en a chez nous et pour n'avoir pas
le 11 10 et voilà et je suis arrivé chez
tati je suis rentré dans le magasin les
musiques j'étais sur le mode froid il
fallait que je m'habille et la personne
avec qui j'étais
m'a proposé d'aller voir je suis allé
voir et en fait j'ai choisi et mentaux
et c'est un manteau d'homme mais là
personne ne m'avait dit que c'était
madonna moi je ne connaissais pas la
différence
pendant ce premier jour il ya des
moments vraiment où je me suis posé la
question est-ce que je suis fait pour
vivre ici est-ce que je vais m'adapter
est ce que je pouvais m'en sortir moi je
suis la petite dernière d'une famille de
sept enfants donc la petite chouchou on
va dire et s'est retrouvé seul ici face
à soi même à la solitude surtout c'était
dur et il ya des moments où j'ai pensé à
retourner chez moi mais je me suis dit
tu as la chance il ya d'autres personnes
qui aimeraient venir
là c'est le magasin dans lequel j'ai vu
il annonce le premier jour que je suis
arrivé j'ai vu une annonce et on cherche
et ilc et hier et là je me suis dit
waouh c'est moi qui suis je suis
caissière et je roule dans le magasin et
je demande à parler à un responsable
donc il ya une charmante dame qui
s'avance vers moi qui ai dit oui c'est
moi qu'est ce que vous voulez j'ai dit
madame j'ai vu une annonce là où
chercher une question m ai dit oui je
suis là et me dit comment je suis
caissière et médias vont vous appréciez
vous avez déjà vous avez des références
bon en tout cas au pays là ma mère elle
l'avait restaurant donc de temps en
temps j'ai encaissé l'argent tout et
tout mais en tout cas je sais ça n ya
pas de prolin et puis j'apprends vite et
comme je venais d'arriver j'ai cofondé
les français fait les français m'a pas
trop de mal et c'est ça une semaine et
dont elle m'a donné mon salaire une
semaine de salaire et là j'étais
tellement heureux ici je suis rentré
chez moi j'ai appelé ma femme et j'ai
dit oui j'ai de l'argent
j'ai reçu pro-saleh pedro mauvaise idée
mais c'est pas grave j'ai un bon salaire
et le fait d'envoyer de l'argent à ma
famille les gens sont tellement fiers
mais jamais je remercie et moi ça m'est
donnée
c'est me donner de la fierté et c'est
pour ça que j'ai voulu tout de suite
trouvé du travail en fait c'était aussi
une façon pour moi de me sentir bien et
de me dire que je suis quelqu'un
voilà je ne suis pas il montre que les
gens voient passer comme ça je suis dit
qu'il fallait que je vis ma vie
pleinement qu'il fallait que je vais
fabule mon destin alors dès que j'ai pu
j'ai démissionné du salon de coiffure je
suis allé mais ce rire ou pleurer auprès
des coups de pierres et j'ai commencé
tout de suite a passé les castings
bon donc ils m'ont paru en 1992
mais je suis devenu une comédienne quand
je vous vois ce soir ici avec moi dans
ce magnifique riad
je suis convaincu que j'ai fait le bon
choix